What are you doing in my room?
What are you doing in here?
How'd you get in here?
You were invited.
The window is broken.
That's why it feels a little breezy.
What are you doing?
you doing in here?
Are you an otaku too?
I wrote that as a reference.
Looking for clues?
I'm innocent.
I swear.
Made burnt.
No, not correct.
Hi Minto.
Hello!
Moe moe boo.
Oh kairi nasaimasu.
Go shijin-sima or joe-sima.
Except...
This is not the maid cafe.
This is my room.
So it's kind of weird to welcome you home.
If it's my...
Room.
We brought snacks for the otaku party!
What's like an otaku snack?
Dr. Peppy.
Hi nerd.
You're cute.
Stop!
Stop it, right?
Pocky?
You guys?
Maybe.
Hello, Minto.
And I booze like you.
My tip for the day?
Keep your room clean.
And just in case Minky visits your room.
I will.
Actually, I felt like I gave a lot of time.
I was like...
I was like, oh, I was gonna do...
this stream on Friday but then I was like oh if I do a
Sunday that gives some people the weekend to clean as well
did you clean I got a whole bowl of strawberry jelly does
that work yes a
little no sort of cleaning clean
Silly side note.
I tried searching for the Borgur emoji for that last super
chat.
It did not work.
They need to give it the times.
It should be Borgur.
You should be able to search Borgur and Borgur.
Joke's on you, I'm not an otaku.
I like normal person things like the sports ball and taxes.
Who likes taxes?
Even normal people like taxes?
like taxes only nerds are gonna like taxes probably you know
numbers numbers numbers oh five hmm what's another number uh
five two uh four um times
I shouldn't have asked you guys.
You guys have bad opinions.
I live in Texas.
Thank you.
Thank you for telling us that.
If I see any Godzilla or Kamen Rider merch in any Ibu's
rooms, they will become my favorite.
I searched through a little bit.
I don't know if I saw any Kamen Rider or Godzilla.
Is it too late to send in a pick?
No, I'm just gonna be going through the rooms.
but yeah uh heads up today might be a little bit of a
shorter stream I apologize I'm feeling funky not funky fresh
funky bad funky negative
funky negative so I'm you know but we'll do this again in
the future so now we'll give you maybe I've even thought I
saw so many people being like I didn't have time to clean.
I was like, do I even do I just wait to do it?
But that's okay.
You streamed a lot yesterday.
I don't even think that's it.
I think it's just, I don't know.
I think I woke up on the wrong side of the bed.
Cleaned, I put the whole shelf together along with a fresh
coat of paint.
Definitely didn't miss a spot on the shelf.
See?
Good job!
Unless you missed a spot and then I'm going to point it and
I will laugh at you.
Put the glasses back on.
It's minting time.
I put my merch in the freezer to keep it cool.
That was it.
That's actually, oh my gosh, what if you have like a little
diorama in your freezer?
All I put in my freezer is Nelson.
So I could put like, I could make it look like Antarctica in
there.
And then every time opens it, which nobody comes over.
They could see every time I feel like opening it.
Not even ice cream?
No?
Well, I have to, I would only be able to do that if somebody
were to like you know, offer me ice cream.
You know what I mean?
Like if it were an offer, for me to take.
No eyes?
I only drink hot water.
I only drink...
I...
I channel my inner Chinese grandma and I only drink hot
water.
Pretty much.
And tea.
Which is, like, hot water.
Hot water on its own?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
With both, both tea and hot water on its own.
It's good, I recommend it.
Hot leaf juice.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Hey, have a thank you for the ice cream.
Ban-kay, thank you so much for the fun.
Get it!
Thank you, thank you.
And now I want ice cream.
Ice cream.
And you know, I said I was having a bit of a funky day.
And I was like, I'm gonna get some of my favorite food.
But the place that I wanted to get food from was closed
today.
And so I said, okay, well, I'll try another place that has
something similar.
And it was not good.
And you know, when you want your favorite food, and you get
like a cheap imitation, it's so...
It just hurts.
I'll go buy a pint.
How are all?
Thank you!
Idea for post-stream emotional recovery get yummy ice cream!
Yeah!
Thanks to our goal!
Sorry I posted an old pic for the review since I haven't
really updated my collection lately, but I promise I did my
New Year's cleaning.
Okay, Gappa, you better pinky promise.
You better...
You better promise me that you're actually clean!
You wouldn't be lying to me now, would you?
You wouldn't lie to this ghost.
Would you?
You lying to this ghost?
You wouldn't download a ghost.
Would you...
That...
What kind of virus would a ghost be like?
Hmm...
What's that like one virus that is like a...
What's it called?
Like a goose that is on your desktop and he sometimes steals
your mouse and things like that.
That's how I feel a ghost might be.
It's kind of moving your icons around a little bit
sometimes.
and then like sometimes you have a like a window open and it
minimizes it my room looks stunning no picks just trust
we're trusting we're trusting I would and have and he closed
on the floor and I'm I'm gonna freak out.
You shouldn't.
Bonzi, but is that what it was called?
Yeah.
Would download the pending.
Are you available for download?
I've been going into the Denzetsu Discord and slowly, like,
very minimally changing people's names.
To see if anybody...
I go and I change, like, one person's name a day.
Just a little bit.
To see if anybody will notice.
I've only done a handful of people.
And I do it when they're like offline.
Maybe they'll notice.
It'll be like a space in between their name.
Very minimal.
Or like, I'll change, like, a letter or something.
That's what I've been doing.
When they'll log on and be Blade Fox, baby.
I could change that to you right now.
Five months, blind fish.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Why are you like this?
Mmm.
I don't know.
Nobody has said.
any well actually i don't know if anybody has said anything
so far because i i um kind of just like hop on post a tick
tock and hop off sometimes
i wish i could do it on youtube also no no one would be safe
but anyway today you guys we're gonna be we're gonna be
looking at your rooms and not our rooms and or collections
depends on how how your room how your collections are set up
i suppose oh thank you so much for the five years thank you
i think this violates the eighth amendment i live in digital
akihabara so i don't know what an amendment is On our way to
change your name.
I hope you liked my dinosaur posting.
I love your dinosaur posting, Colvo.
I love it.
So, let's get small.
Actually, not too small.
Oh, let's get close.
Let's get close.
I'm right here.
I'm going to be looking at your room.
Our collections.
I don't really have like a, how to say, a method for this.
I'm just, we're just kind of winging it a little bit.
We're just kind of, we're just kind of going for it a little
bit.
So, wait, let me move my stuff around a bit.
You're sick!
No, Joshua, feel better!
No, don't be sick.
No!
All those headpats are for you.
Stop being sick right now!
If it makes you feel better, I'm in the late stages of it.
Wait!
Oh, the disease or...
No, the cold!
Oh!
Put on a jacket, silly.
Don't be cold.
It's winter.
What are you doing?
So for those who...
Spank!
Did you offer me some ice cream?
A little drumstick?
What else do you have on here?
mushroom and a cheesy chicken and rice and a lean lean plus
cuisine I can't oh Alfredo pasta with what is that what is
this Alfredo pasta with even with my glasses on I oh wait I
just realized it's cut off a little bit sorry the my
Formatting is a little funky because I had to form, like,
I'll just adjust per image.
Oh, there we go.
That doesn't look like a room.
Obviously, they are a food otaku.
They are a food otaku, clearly.
And then a warm, hearty, and delicious.
Oh, nice.
Oh, you got the meat stacked up here.
And a single...
this chicken parmesan are we going newest oldest we're going
however I feel kind of so basically um I'm just kind of I
kind of like click what interests me so could be anything I
like seeing people's collections vtubers and But especially,
I like seeing collections that are other than VTuber.
Yeah.
Let's see what else we got in here.
And then I'm also checking Twitter.
And I'm checking Blue Sky.
Whee!
Coolpads.
Nyaruko collection is so cute!
Wait, it looks so good!
Wait, I love these!
Like the...
Wait, uh...
The three different ones, but it's the same pose?
Didn't you used to have a Nyaruko profile picture, or am I
crazy?
I'll go back and forth.
I'll do one Twitter, one Blue Sky.
If Kobuts is here.
Oh, crazy, I think.
I guess I'm crazy.
This one's cute too though.
Are these Dojin?
Wait a second.
I see...
Oh, it does say four Dojinchi.
I need to learn to read.
Ah!
Oh!
What do we have here?
Are these...
VINALS?
Are these all VINALS?
Oh my god.
This fuck ass com- com- com- com- com- When are we gonna get
rid of the grandma com- Comforter, you guys?
I have already!
I'm already Was it your room?
It couldn't have been.
There's more than one of you that has this comforter.
I know it.
A teacup looking ass bed over here.
It's comfy, though.
It's the same one.
It is, isn't it?
I'm certain somebody said she liked it last time.
Yeah, I love it.
That's why I remember it.
Someone said that these are laser discs.
Wait, look, Indiana Jones is in Japanese!
Wait, Stalker, what is this one?
Wait, why is Casper also in- Wait, these are in Japanese!
James and the Giant Peach!
Total Recall!
In Japanese!
I bet there's decorative shampoo somewhere.
Laser Disc was more popular in Japan.
Oh, so cool!
Wow, wait.
Wow!
Oh, it's out there now.
Wait, this is such an awesome collection.
This is my special interest!
I love collecting anime dishware.
So I have lots of plates and bowls and lots and lots of
cups.
Let's see what...
This is...
This is my special interest.
I like the way you've displayed them.
I actually use mine, but...
Me.
I actually use mine.
But I like the way you've displayed them.
Because some of them, I'm kind of lazy if I put it in the
dishwasher.
Some of them have faded away.
I have, like, a Keys in an Eye one, and she's, like, a
ghost.
special week where?
where?
Oh, there she is.
She's teeny tiny.
I like these ones.
Nanoha one.
Oh, wait.
Did you put?
Oh, you put like little papers on the birds.
It's good.
it's good the boards yeah we got some boards in there
I like how you like put the paper in there so you could see
the design better that's nice that's a good idea and then
the cure oh there's special week too oh my gosh I don't even
notice her I like this one what I've never seen this Xi
Marin It's cute, it's cute Oh Oh, I remember this I remember
this Sorry it's cut off a little bit Very cute, very cute
Good collection Good collection Thanks, Kohlbats Let's see I
want to see How
many times did you have to do this wait i don't remember
this one wait or i don't remember this one this is so cute
these are so cute minto maxing the bag is cute everything is
cute
i like this one in the box it's from your minto cafe club it
must have been maybe one of the uh so i got my merch from
the cafe collab but um but i couldn't uh she gave me all
like the uh like ayami mama gave me all like the regular
merch but she didn't give me there was nothing from the the
the lottery because that was all sold out completely so i
didn't get anything from the lottery so even though i kind
of wanted like the big, big tapestry and everything.
It was a war zone.
Well, you know, if a cafe happens again this year, I hope
everybody who's able to go has a better chance.
If it happens this year.
Wow!
Oh, wait a second.
It's cropped.
It's cropping of funny...
It was fun, yeah?
Why are my panties out like that?
I survived the spit and greet.
Aw, and our postcard and everything.
These are so cute.
And you got to see Kesey.
You tell us, it's not official merch.
It's Fennar.
Why are my panties?
out why I'm here for the spit and greet these are so funny
that you got two different things cute cute cute cute I wish
I decorated more sorry that it's Maybe we should have
decorated more on yours.
Hmm.
I'll decorate better next time.
Thank you, Top Mr. Am.
Wait, you have more stuff?
Oh!
Hold.
Wait, I like your display so much.
Look at all the Nendo's.
This one is foul.
because it's so evil it's so cute look at the fleshies at
the bottom look so cute look this is all displayed so nicely
this is so nice it's so clean like look at the oh wait oh
you opened it I was like wait what is this like this this
corner it's so nice though everything is so clean it's so
organized wow wow Wow!
Wow, it's so, and the lighting and everything!
I'm a fan, I'm a fan!
This looks so nice!
I love how much room the taco takes off.
It's so funny.
Minto spotted.
Me!
Everything looks so nice!
This is, I feel like, a really great argument for framing
your posters and stuff, you guys.
When you frame, like, putting your posters up is fine,
whatever, you know, but if you frame them, it really, like,
adds a level of, like, I don't know, like, hominess and,
and, uh, like, it just, it looks, I don't want to say,
professional is not the right word.
But it, class, yeah, it's very classy.
And you don't have to get expensive frames or anything like
even just like a very simple one like this there you can
find them I have I get a bunch for like five dollars you
know and Yeah it's it really elevates your your your
aesthetic your room and everything is it really really is
ours yeah yeah so I recommend a hundred percent
We got Legos!
Wait, what?
There's like one-piece Legos and everything?
Oh my gosh, the Overwatch Lego.
Whoa!
Star Wars!
Oh my gosh, wait, the Yellow Submarine!
Oh my gosh, wait, these are so cute!
All the little cars and stuff, the different like vehicles.
These are so cute!
Those Avatar Legos are so rare.
Really?
I've had a social media account for years, so I had to make
a Blue Sky account.
If you don't get to it, no worries.
Can't wait to submit for the next one.
I get all my birthday density merch.
Camp patrol!
Thank you!
Oh, you didn't have to make an account just for this,
though.
Also, first punch, happy birthday!
Yeah, the mystery machine and the DeLorean.
I'm guessing that's...
That looks like...
That looks like Back to the Future.
And the Ghostbusters...
To keep them away from me, though, obviously.
This is so cute!
I like whatever this shelving is.
I prefer the ones with like the like ink enclosed, you know,
and like glass or something.
I prefer mine to be glass all around so that I can but
actually I really like this.
Oh.
Getting inspiration.
My own inspiration.
Oh.
At the beginning.
Thank you!
Top of Mr. M.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's see.
Let's see what we got here.
Oh, hi rice knot!
Did it.
Oh.
Let's get it.
Oh, not scoot that over.
Wait, what is that?
Oh.
Um, yeah.
That's me!
That's you!
Wow, big Ryza fan.
Big Ryza fan.
Wow, wow, look at her everywhere.
Thysa, Thysa, Thysa.
This is, I really, what are these details or...
I love this Miku figure.
Love, love, love.
I have this figure too.
The one down here.
I haven't seen the alt one though.
That's cute.
I don't know.
I'm...
I see, I see, I see.
I see, I see.
When you see someone with like a figure and you're just
like, I'm...
You're like, I know, I know.
Yeah, I know, I know.
Yeah.
Rainbow Dash?
Is she your pony?
This is cute.
The Helltaker.
That's cute.
How do you?
Thais.
God damn.
Look what the Bukia MLPs are cute.
I really wanted... What's her name?
her name but she was like the the Chrysalis Queen her I
really liked her figure I liked her pony in design in
general because I like the the holes in her arms and stuff
her name is Chrysalis okay okay okay yeah yeah I like the
holes in her and her legs so good so cool for a second I
thought this was censored and This too, I thought these were
censored.
Like with mosaic for a second.
It kind of, oh my gosh, my brain like can't unsee it.
She's a change like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cute.
Wait, these are so cute.
Oh.
Cute, cute.
This is league, isn't it?
Ooh.
Nice figure collection.
Nice figure.
I should have taken a picture of my collection.
I meant to and I completely forgot.
Sorry guys.
But um...
Thank you for...
Maybe next time I'll clean up.
I'll clean up.
Next time though I do this might be after I've moved.
So I've been like kind of getting rid of some figures.
getting rid of some stuff in preparation for me moving so
Benjamin oh watching Ollie on the telly
wait your collection is so clean like your room is so clean
usually I'm not a huge fan of like these insert like these
like you know what What do you call them?
Uh...
Like the little box inserts that are like fabric, fabric,
that's the word.
Um...
But...
They look nice here.
It looks really nice.
You got your little collection here.
You got more VTubers up here.
Peek on me!
I have this pillow, but I have like the big version of it.
And she's on my couch.
Yeah.
I'm watching Ollie.
This is cute.
This is so cute.
I like the way you frame these down here.
This looks really nice.
I like getting ideas from you guys for decorating.
Wow!
Wait, I like this shelf.
This is so cute!
He lifts?
All the...
Wait, everything is...
like organized so well.
It almost looks like a rainbow.
I like how Bales is upside down.
I'm sure that's on purpose.
That's really funny actually.
Everything's like color coded.
What?
Aussie pride.
So cute.
Wow.
Taco duchy.
Whoa.
And you read, you have like actual books.
I noticed them in the other picture too.
Whoa!
Your description says my small and comfy apartment.
But like this is, this is really nice.
Oh my god.
The Pokemon.
Wait, this is so nice.
The Pokemon bedsheets.
Dog.
Look at that dog.
I feel like this is the perfect...
I'd like you to have like a shelf to kind of like separate
your desk and everything.
Like this is a...
This is really nice.
Isn't it a nice place?
Yeah, Sonic Colony here.
Big Holo Fan.
Cute.
How did you get this picture?
Is that your kitchen?
Looks like a kitchen.
Hmm...
We have the Garupan up there.
It's like the only thing besides Pokemon that's like a...
And Miku here.
That's like the only thing that's not VTuber related.
Don't look at their kitchen.
Why not?
If I come over, I want to know where the food is at.
You can see this security camera.
Oh, you can.
Ah, you can.
You can, you can, you can right there.
I thought it was like you just stand really far in the
corner.
Very nice.
Very nice, Benjamin.
Benjamin.
Can I pet the dog?
That's not for me to say yes or no to.
That's not for me.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Skeletons!
I saw your...
put this one earlier one second sorry i keep having to like
adjust i saw this and i was so excited because look at the
lupan of like the the zaku shelf and then and now the lupan
is so cool
Yeah, char-
You're maxing.
Thanks for the donut!
Zaku-Kiri.
Yeah, yeah, I've seen this before.
Quite a bit.
I like how this is like...
It's like yaoi shelves.
Both are yaoi shelves.
I didn't know.
Is this their pairing?
this is so funny because it looks like the the bad guy for
like so in detective conan they um they um uh when before
you know who like the the the criminal is they uh they are
like this shadow person and so it looks like this shadow
person from Conan but yeah all you see are their eyes and
their mouth that's it and like it's become kind of a meme
because it's like a very simple design obviously but it's so
iconic so it's very very iconic like you'll see him you'll
see him in like because he's drawn a very specific way so
They did an anime about the design.
Oh, really?
I don't think I saw it.
I love this, though.
The...
What is that called?
Like, the needlework.
But...
That's so stinking cute.
That's a Lupon shelf.
I'm obsessed.
That is my pairing, yes.
Thank you for checking out Blue Sky 2.
And yeah, that Shadow Guy is from Castle...
Oh, yes, yes, yes!
Also animated by TMS.
I can never say the name of a castle of...
Cagliostro.
Embroidery.
Thank you.
Cross stitch?
Is it cross stitch?
Looks more like embroidery.
I don't know.
I'm not a...
What's the word?
An expert.
My brain is super foggy today.
I can't think of anything.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Close enough.
Oh!
They need a bath Look at that dust Wash them Are they so old
that like You know when figures get really really When you
have like a really old figure And it gets that like sticky
Film on it You know I have a bunch of those like that Like I
have like a couple galaxy angel ones You have to like I try
to give my Figures a bath.
Charmero.
Yummy film.
You could just suck on it if you want.
I wonder what kind of taste it is, though.
Sticky film.
It's a sticky film.
Yeah, you gotta give them a little bath.
Give them a bath.
Oh, this is so cute!
You always go to your Pokemon things.
This is so cute.
Pokemon eat a bag.
Cute, cute, cute.
I love the theming.
Everything is so good.
Nice.
Thank you, Skeletal.
What the hell?
Do you guys know Utsi?
The Frozen Caveman?
What they found?
That's what this reminds me of.
A mitzvah.
The ice man.
I can hear I don't want a lot for Christmas plague already.
It's time!
Bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing.
BANG BANG BANG BANG BANG BANG BANG BANG BANG No, I think
defrosting would be...
What would defrost?
What would be my song to defrost?
Ah...
I mean, I guess it could be welcome to Mint Cafe.
Or Mint Cafe, sorry.
Ice Minky, what are you doing?
Get out of there!
I'm cozy, I'm cozy.
Santa baby!
Hey, Minta, why the cold shoulder?
Looking cool, Minto.
This is not what I said when I said I wanted ice cream!
This is not what I meant!
Why did you freeze me?
Why?
Why am I frozen?
you need to chill
let's see what else we got here oh this is so cool Seymour I
love your photography so it says a collection of portable
photo printers from left to right a thermal sticker printer
an Instax SP2 for minis then Instax SP3 for squares a selfie
cp 1500 for 4x6 print wow so cool oh sorry i was i was going
over each one i love the stickers wait don't thermal
stickers though because it's like a you know kind of like a
receipt wouldn't it rub off eventually which is kind of so
sad but it looks so good
It's unique.
Yeah!
Thermals do fade after a while.
Surprisingly, it works fine.
Oh, really?
Just don't rub the stickers.
Eat it before it does.
So true?
It's Mike.
Jazz Show.
Where is this one from, Seymour?
The vet with the fully coolie Vespa.
And this one, too.
This, this, this, I, this is from the, this is from Holman.
Right?
I remember you gave me these pictures.
They're so cute.
So cute.
I wanna, I wanna, oh my gosh, having a, wait, having like
one of these digital photo frames, though, for like Oshi
pictures is kind of genius.
Like it just cycles through like you know pictures of your
Oshi.
Wait that's kind of genius.
Wait that's so smart.
Wait.
I got that frame from Goobweil and I load in new pictures
all the time.
Wait that's awesome.
Wait that's so smart.
It doesn't have to be for normie things like babies and
pets.
It can also be for it can also be for your oshi or whatever
weeb things yeah wait i kind of want to get one now what is
this takumar 50 50 millimeter lens sitting on top of a
geiger counter
It reads 1.44 micro...
How do you say that?
Seavorts?
The card is overlaid on top of the Geiger counter to show
when it's dangerous.
It could be high enough to warrant caution, but the
radiation from the lens is blocked by skin.
And when attached to a camera is blocked by the camera body.
What?
Wait, which reading would it be?
Oh wait, it's this one.
Oh, it's this one, okay.
Only mildly radioactive.
Mildly radioactive.
Radioactive.
Not good, not bad.
That's crazy, I never knew it was like that.
Oh my gosh, Seattle!
Washington!
That's Alan Wake!
Oh my god.
Thank you so much, Seymour, for the really cool collection.
Let's see what else we got in here.
There was something I wanted to look at more, because I
remember seeing it, and I was like, this is so cool.
And I want to...
Oh, here!
I found it.
Hamburger.
I love this.
their love of wrestling and also and also vtubers it's so
good what is hope my sub on blue sky made the cut Farlander
thank you welcome back I'm just kind of scrolling through
stuff so if I get to it I'd love to look at it and all the
doobies this is this This is sick.
This jacket is so awesome.
Kappa Rider Club.
It's so, it looks so good.
It looks so, so good.
That's me, down here.
This is so good!
I don't know so much about wrestling, so...
But look, look, look!
Is that me with Maki Ito?
Mint in the hurt syndicate.
She hurts us.
Resultober.
I bet you really like that.
Wait!
You posted this picture!
I saw this recently!
The boom!
I saw this recently on on on on on on Twitter.
Oh, the photos are so cute.
Like the Oshikatsu is so good.
The Maki Ito, yeah, is the cutest idol wrestler in the
world.
This is so good.
This is so stinking good.
Oh my god.
Wait, I didn't see this picture.
This is...
Wow.
Oh my god.
This is too good.
What is this?
This is so good.
How it wake!
Oh my god!
The cardboard cutouts.
I feel like every...
benefits from a cardboard cutout.
You know what I'll do, you guys?
I'm going to get artwork commissioned.
And I'm going to give it to you guys so you can make your
own cardboard cutout if you'd like.
I'll get you the art.
And so it can be a cardboard cutout that you can make and
put in your room.
I feel like a room is really complete with a cardboard
cutout.
Hell yeah!
I mean obviously I can't do the cardboard cutout for you,
but all you have to do is order it and get it.
Bay is still upside down.
Wait where?
She's right so- oh there she is upside down!
Oh my god!
This is- I know this skeleton!
This is so funny!
Everything is- everything is too good!
It's so funny.
Also, Matara signed this.
See her signature is right here on John Cena Momo.
I want to know, though, Hamburger Kun, if you do these
photoshopped.
Or if you get somebody else to.
Because, like...
Like, this is so funny.
It's so good.
And you have so much variety of, like, VTubers.
Other stuff, too.
Like, I see, like, other anime and stuff, too.
But, like, you seem just so supportive of so many people.
That's really awesome.
Thank you so much.
Oh, I photoshopped them myself!
Oh, my God!
Yeah, the movement poster is so cute.
I'm such a fan.
I think I'm a fan of you.
Ah!
You made it into a acrylic stand!
It just gets better and better.
Aww, the doobie stuff!
Doobie!
Doobie, doobie!
Oh, Ashton!
Oh wow!
Wow, thank you, Hamburger, for sharing.
I love seeing your photos when you post them, so thank you
very much.
This is so...
So funny.
Wandering Taco!
Thank you so much!
Thank you for the 20 gifts, thank you, thank you!
Let's see, let's see...
Let's do this one!
Oh,
let me scoot over, but...
I'm so honored, I'm always underneath Marion.
In a good way.
Wow, so fun!
Oh my gosh, thank you for getting...
Oh my gosh, there's so many things I recognize, thank you.
you thank you thank you the best way yeah bottoming for
sensho is a privilege of course of course these are both
beautiful shelves thank you and you even came wait i'm
blocking it but i see that you uh not off kai last year but
the year before last um you came to my meet and greet
Cute, cute, cute, cute.
Is this censored?
Is that censored?
Minto and her wives and mom and wine aunt.
Yeah, it's like me and Kiara and Nibby.
And hence.
Is this like a Niki show?
Is this sensor?
Hot dog.
Very cute collection.
Thank
you for sharing.
Let's see.
Rokai says, behold my messy dusty Otaku room.
Wait.
Expand.
There we go.
Alright, let's see what we've got in here.
First of all.
Why?
Your monitor is blocking this whole detour find here.
I see some Miku, see Kiwawa's...
Wait, who is that?
I can't tell.
Is that... that's not...
Oh my gosh, I have this!
This Yuki plushie too!
I see Kurisutina.
I have so many questions.
Okay, wait.
I have some questions.
So...
Like...
Oh wait, is this the Lego Game Boy?
It's so nice.
What are these?
Why are there like little chairs on your desk?
Who are they for?
The bugs?
Like...
Hot dog gotcha.
Chairs for Barry.
Yeah, for the bugs.
It looks like you're, you have like a little bit of a, like,
you know, like a tiny model set.
Like those, those are like garbage cans, like garbage
separators.
But...
This is...
Yeah.
Um...
Who is it?
Whose body is in here?
Look, just Mikasha on the table.
You have a lot of... I'm guessing these are games?
Maybe?
A lot of games?
Or DVDs or something?
Churno Fumo.
No, this is Yuki from Haruhi.
Nagato Yuki.
Looks like it might be Mari, baby.
It's quite red.
Too many questions, Mito.
I'm just I like these but I'm pretty sure those are don't
tell me don't tell me that these are like finger
fingerprints in the dust you did say dusty room I'm just
trying to make sense of some of it oh yeah you are watching
Kiwawa playing Metroid I don't know how I didn't even notice
that.
Tycho drum at the bottom.
Yeah, I see it down here.
I'm blocking some, like, cosplay photos here.
I see Yaya Han.
That's an old one.
I remember that.
Yeah.
See some figures.
You like to put Kiara and Black Rock Shooter together.
Oh, wait.
That makes so much sense.
I'm such an idiot.
As soon as I came out of my lips, I was like, Oh, duh,
because...
Sorry.
At first I was like, why?
Why?
That's such an odd combo.
Neurons connecting literally in real time, as I said it.
Yorami!
Welcome to Bubbleship!
Thank you!
Yeah, Saint Papa, everybody.
Saint Papa.
And also for Steinsgate too.
Good KFP.
Well, thank you, Rokai.
This was both quizzical and fun.
I enjoyed my time.
I mean, yeah.
Let's see what else we got here.
Oh, oh, oh!
We have, who is this?
I clicked on the picture.
O-M-R, creations.
Da-da.
Look at, what, look at all these get, I like the way you
displayed your games on the wall.
Wait, that's so fun.
Well, what if you want to play one?
Me?
You!
Oh, Metal Gear!
Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear,
Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gears, Metal Gears!
Wow, sorry I'm blocking some of them, but this is a street
fighter.
One of the fighting games.
I'm so not versed.
Tiamante.
Oh, Metal Gears!
Metal Gears!
An Odin sphere.
Wait, this is something.
nice I like the solidus wait that's so nice
and your little collection I like I like the glove is on the
glove stays on metal gear very nice very clean shelves I'm a
fan what is this speaker for ambiance the infinity gauntlet
what is the speaker for sound speaking sound i would like
omr to answer oh this is my theater setup oh cool oh my gosh
oh hold on wait a
second one yeah the mystique is really cool your laptop.
Oh my gosh.
You studied the blades.
Wait.
Is this a Thunder Cats blade?
A sword.
This one on the bottom, right?
Is that Thunder Cats?
Thunder, thunder, thunder.
Yes!
It's so cool i love it i love these guys too oh oops sorry i
can't see them i love these guys up here flying up here
that's awesome that's so cool thank you for sharing thunder
cats oh
let's see what else we got
Wait a second!
Thank you for enjoying!
Thanks for sharing!
Wait a second!
Oh wait, one second?
Kitty!
I have a decent sized collection of mint merch from
conventions to the Phantom Thief Concert and Asayoreme Cafe.
I love 3D printing eyeballs!
Oh my gosh!
Blue Blaze!
They're so cute!
cute and little eye boos I want to like 3d print some and
like hand out to people and stuff too I love the kitty it's
kind of mellow hi mellow I got one of those eye boos you do
wait what is it
how did you get your cat to eat me the prop shown is over
five feet tall oh what prop let's see whoa whoa what is this
display whoa whoa it's so i've never seen whoa it's like
hanging it's i've never seen something like
Gothaminkid What was I playing?
I wonder Wow Cute Oh that's me playing Owl and Wike I like
the computer has so many stickers and things It's really
cute That's cute Wait a second What is this?
What is it wished for?
What this court is The rules.
Wait.
Oh, the keyboard's cute.
Hmm.
Leaked.
Oh, wow.
The 3D print.
Whoa.
I want to see some other things that you've 3D printed
before.
Oh, making props for cars.
the prop shown.
I'm guessing this one is five feet tall.
That's like almost as tall as me!
Cruzy.
Wait, I want to see more of your props.
You should have shown more of those.
Cool.
So cool!
Taller.
No.
Nice.
I like how it's like hidden away in your closet very cool
blue blaze thanks for printing the artworks thank you thank
you oh i love it
let's see back to blue sky
let's see oh Camp control!
Ta-da!
Wait, wait a second, let's scoot it over a bit.
Your room is so lively!
There's so much in here!
Hey, that's me, that's you!
And that's me!
That's me, and that's me, and that's me!
What are you obsessed with me or something?
Wait, do you stream?
What's your goxler doing here?
You're with the fire truck?
Is that a transformer?
You've got so much going on in there.
Whoa!
They're novels.
Wow.
I like the open box setup.
That's cool.
That's really cool.
And my...
My...
My guys.
is also posed as a piece.
My arm.
Very clean setup.
Yeah, this looks really nice.
I like how you just took out the shelves.
What the hell is...
What?
It's like Yoda and Shrek had a baby.
What the hell is that thing?
That's not baby.
Yoda what is this thing what is it oh my gosh you have a
fuggler do you think they're fuggly do you like the fugglers
they're like really fugglers are really big in pan right
now.
Because everybody's giving me opposite.
You guys know a fuggler?
You guys know the fugglers?
These guys, they're really ugly.
They have like realistic teeth like this, you know?
They have like actual teeth.
They're very It's very popular in Japan right now.
The Fuggler.
See, you guys have to choose.
You have to choose between the Labubu and the Fuggler.
You have to choose either Labubu or Fuggler.
No, I do not.
One day they'll collab.
I have a rainbow rabbit fuggler.
He's so ugly.
I love him.
My stupid son.
Yeah, it's very like kimo kawaii.
Like just like ugly, cute.
Some people don't think they're cute at all though.
They're...
Wow!
Oh my gosh, the more I see.
So cool!
I am such a huge sucker for like props like these from video
games.
I think they look so cool.
I feel like they really enhance a collection.
Like, like they just like kind of like life size props of
stuff.
Just look so awesome.
Yeah I see if I see him.
Snack.
Feet.
Wait, where do you see feet?
I don't see any.
I choose Sesame Street.
The Muppets are Neo Pets.
Don't spend your money like I do I booze.
Also, I had to reply to that post to get the last shelf.
Oh, there's one more.
Chinese food and Minto stream.
Today is a good day.
Chinese food sounds so good!
Wait, I kind of want Chinese food.
Hmm.
Wait, hold on, let me...
You had the reply, you said.
Okay, can't control.
I'm gonna have to clown on you for a little bit.
What the hell?
What is...
What the hell is going on here?
Are those supposed to be blackout curtains?
Please invest in a steamer.
What is happening?
No, it's awesome.
No, it's...
Okay, wait, I know Doom Guy.
Oh, wow, look at the persona mask, too.
It's so cool.
But this one, oh gosh, what's the name of the, what's the
game's name?
I had a, it blocks out light.
Home.
Dead space.
Yes, thank you.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, and my brain kept wanting to say Bioshock, and I was
like, no, that's not it.
That's not it.
Invest in a steamer?
No, I prefer investing in a streamer.
Honestly, though, steamers are so good, you guys.
They're great for getting out wrinkles very easily, like
this.
And you don't have to pull out a whole ironing board and
things like that.
Get a steamer.
That's like my, that's my real world advice for you.
Investing in this steamer.
True and real.
Thank you, Campin' Jero!
Thank you for sharing.
Oh my gosh, your profile picture is so cute.
Wait, before we go to...
Back to Twitter.
Chocolate.
Ironing board?
Why are you saying it like that, huh, Spank?
Why are you saying it like that, huh?
Look at the carby's!
So much carbo!
Wow, this is so cute!
Carbo!
A pack of steamer with me when I travel.
It's such a handy thing.
I know!
I'm telling you guys.
It will enhance your life or afterlife.
Look!
And...
Oh, this is so cute!
Wow!
Kirby's Dream, man.
We played that.
There's so much Kirby!
This is so cute.
Play-oh!
I want to play the...
I've heard good things about...
What is it?
Air Rider or whatever?
I want to play it.
And look at the cartridges and everything.
Everything's all displayed.
Wow Wow Wow Wow So cute Play-O Wow Wow Wow you have like
everything So cute Is this like every game?
And the 3DS even
Viewer content with Air Riders?
Wait, is it like multiplayer?
If not, it's darn close.
Almost all of them.
Wow!
Wow.
It looks like every game.
That's crazy.
So fun.
Wait, in Air Riders, can I play as Meta Knight?
It's better with multiplayer.
Can I play as him?
I can!
Oh my god, there he is.
He's literally right there.
Wait, what's his name again?
Hold on, don't tell me.
Don't tell me.
Don't tell me, don't tell me, don't tell me, don't tell me,
don't tell me.
Oh, whoa,
whoa, whoa.
Waddle do?
Waddle do.
Close.
Waddle D!
Waddle D's.
I kind of like Waddle do better.
Thank you for sharing your Corbel collection.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, K-Bard.
More transformers.
It's kind of insane how many...
Whoops.
How many people, like, collect transformers.
And, like, when you collect transformers, you...
Like, most people are like, I collect transformers.
You know, like, it's not like a...
It's not a small endeavor.
It's always, like, it's always like the biggest...
collections ever my question for the whips is that wasps I
boost how often do you dust your room I have a pile of that
sits in dust in the corner I'm too lazy to organize oh well
for me I dust like I try to dust like once a week but it's
also like what's the word like
My place is abandoned, so it doesn't...
I plead the fifth.
You guys should always dust, though.
Holy cow!
Who's Roshi?
Oh my god!
Do
you like shockwaves?
That's crazy!
Oh my gosh, yeah, that's fun boy.
Oh!
Oh my god, oh my god!
Okay, Barn, if you're here, how long did this...
How long did this take for this collection?
This is insanity.
This is so much.
Holy cow.
Dustin, your home is mainly made of your own dead skin.
So in a way, the dust will protect your items, much like
your skin protects you.
What about the fur then?
Oh, there you are.
It started in 2001.
It sounds like a saga.
It all began.
In 2001.
Oh my god.
Glad you did mine first.
This collection rules.
Oh my god.
This is so good.
I'm so honored to be in the middle of all of this, honestly.
I don't feel like we deserve to be here.
I feel like...
This collection is insane!
Tiny
the miniatures, oh my god.
Wow.
Okay, Martin, I really hope you don't live in a place that
is prone to earthquakes.
Kitty!
Oh my god, does your cat try to get into the stuff?
This is a temple.
This is truly a museum.
This is so awesome.
Definitive Otaku.
Thank
you for sharing.
Thank you for sharing.
the wallpaper is courtesy of the 40th anniversary music
video studio trigger and bump of chicken did two years ago
and no kit is very well behaved i learned something today i
don't know if you guys saw that tweet as well that came if
it came up in your timeline but it was like talking about
japanese band names and it was they were talking about bump
of chicken which Apparently, the Japanese for Bump of
Chicken is like...
What was it?
The Bump of Chicken one.
Yeah, yeah!
It was like...
Um...
It was like something about like...
Going against... Like, yeah, Revenge of the Coward!
I see a little space left at the bottom slagging.
Of mad respect for this cat.
They've never knocked over these.
Yeah.
But apparently it's supposed to be like revenge of the
coward.
Because like when you bump like a chicken is like another.
It's like a synonym for a coward.
And then chickens when they fight they kind of like bump
chests and stuff.
So it's supposed to be like.
Like a chicken's fighting or something.
It's very bizarre.
And then there was like a whole like thread of.
explanations for I've always wondered why they were called
Bump of Chicken.
I never knew.
and they were like there was other people explaining like
other Japanese band names.
Like one okay rock is supposed to be one one a claw.
It's supposed to I guess in Japanese one okuroku one okay
One o'clock.
But one o'clock like it, I never questioned it because I was
like, oh you're a band, it's whatever.
One o'clock.
It's so good.
Yeah.
It's so funny.
But...
There was another one.
There was another one that I read about.
And I was like, what?
Oh, wow, I never...
Oh, the Gazette.
They were... Oh, what was it?
They were not like a gazette, like a newspaper.
It was something else.
Ah!
Cassette!
Right, right, right!
It's a play-on cassette!
Like a cassette tape.
Oh, it's so funny.
It's so funny how the...
The bands are.
Page!
This guy is so cute!
I like the mint chocolate float you have going on there.
My glasses.
Wait!
You got one of the buzzwords!
Shikishi!
Gosh!
I wish I had more time to decorate them more.
I kind of just like I had to go to the office and like sign
them and go pretty much but wow i'm a lucky fella well no
but your your buttons i wish i could go to everybody who has
a button that is i saw someone else saying that their
buttons are um the ink is coming off i wish i could like go
and redo all of them oh cute emery
Yeah, Moody.
Aww.
I like the wood.
These are so cute.
Wait, this is like supposed to be a name tag, right?
You should write your name on that.
Hello?
Shoebill!
So cute!
Wood.
Hello, Pyram.
Hello?
Pyra.
That's me.
I love how...
Paige, what is going on here?
You have all these Goku's.
And then Pyra.
They're just...
They're just out and about.
This is a really... What is this?
Like one...
One-fourth scale?
Right!
Probably.
Maybe.
He's big.
The five Goku's are teaming up to take down Pyra.
No, I think it's definitely bigger than one-sixth.
I think it's one-fourth.
That's one-fourth.
She's small.
But if she stands up, it's like one-fourth, but on her
knees.
It's one-fourth.
I told you.
I know my figures.
And I know my figure sizes.
I told you all.
You say one-sixth.
No, I argue you.
I told you.
Don't question my authority.
Thanks, Paige!
It was very cute.
Very cute collection.
Let's go back to blue sky.
Let's see what we got.
I'm going through.
Sorry, also, if your collection does not make it, like I
said, I'll be doing it again.
But also, I'm kind of just picking things that, like, meet
my eyes.
like you know so it's not that you have a bad collection
it's just me kind of like I'm trying to what's the word I
like to get a kind of variety going on like so this is real
Runa with a scissor collection Wow
A scissor collection.
I've never thought of somebody collecting scissors.
Wait, I have that cinnamarol blue eyes with dragon also.
Wait, I like the cinnamarol scissors too and the Karomi
scissors.
Wait, these are scissors!
Fumoko?
They're cute!
Cool.
yet worrying.
I like these ones too in their sleeves.
It's like I've never seen someone decorate their wall with
scissors.
Phoebe!
It's a Phoebe.
May dream?
Your wall is so cute!
Yippee!
That's how Phoebe says it.
Cute and pushing.
I've never seen anyone decorate with scissors before.
I'm so fascinated.
What?
I'm curious though what dictates whether they're shut like
this or whether they're open?
Hmm.
if they like kill the kill oh right right yeah a cosplayer
what to do do crafts like what it's so cool though vibes
gravity maybe it would make me want to search for the like
most unique scissors you know like some of these like this
one definitely looks like a craft scissor but this is like
what the hell this one even looks pretty fancy like even
just the cute designs on them like it's Maybe a stationary
washi tape otaku.
Oh, maybe it.
So fun.
Oh my gosh, I didn't even see the Kiara tapestry.
Wow, that's awesome.
That's so nice.
Wait, this is so cool.
Thank you for sharing.
Wow.
He says, here's my computer desk featuring my scissor
collection on the wall.
Wow.
So cool!
Uh...
Let's see.
Hmm.
Do-do-do-do-do.
Do-do-do-do.
I'm scrolling.
I'm looking.
I'm observing.
I'm looking at everybody's rooms.
Oh my gosh, Orca.
The dolls in your room are so cute.
The Orca pluses are so cute.
Drossil.
That's my robot wife.
I love her.
I'm currently out of town right now.
This is all I have in my camera roll for my collection.
bird.
Oh, cute!
Wait!
Are these like decks themed to each of us?
That's me!
That's you!
Wait, this is so cute!
They're so cute!
Oh my gosh, the little matching stickers and everything!
That's really...
Oh, my gosh.
Oh my gosh, that's such a cute idea.
And I like how each of us have like the blue and the mint.
Nimmies looks red?
I can't tell if it's because of the table or not though.
The colored sleeves are satisfying.
Yeah, yeah!
This is so stinking cute.
Legendary creature spirit warrior.
I like that Nimmies got dinosaur.
For evil Nimi.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
Cute!
I love this.
Love your card collection.
Thank you for sharing.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's see what we got else.
Toot, toot, toot, toot.
This person says...
Oh, whoops.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Oh, okay, good.
Okay, we're good.
This person said I did not clean my room.
Wait, let me double check these before I...
Oh my god.
You play drums?
Maybe?
Oh.
Where are your sheets?
Where are your bed sheets?
Oh, you really like Arizona.
Oh no, green teeth.
That's pretty good.
We're gaming?
R slash male living space.
A single can.
What's this one?
I don't know this brand.
The 3DS?
On top of them.
Honestly, the whole...
You have a lot of clutter around here, but this is like very
cleanable.
Honestly, like it could be worse.
Like your floor looks like it could be worse.
I have faith in you.
Fazbear Fanta.
It is!
That's a pretty Fazbear?
Oh, it does say Fanta.
You're right.
This doesn't look so bad to clean up.
Look, you got a printer.
And you're very...
Uh...
Resourceful.
You don't have a table for it, so you're using a box.
And the painting looks very nice.
And you're doing renovations, obviously.
And that's why you have...
Uh...
All you just gotta do is vacuum.
Oh, those are MREs.
A lot of them.
But you also like mac and cheese and a burrito?
Look at the wall.
What?
I saw.
Nice, Sarah.
This is so cute!
Oh my gosh, pin collection!
Wow!
Look at all the pins!
Wait, are these like locations that you've been to?
Bigfoot?
Wait, this is such a cute way to display them.
Wow!
And the plushy hammock?
This is so cute!
I like how all the white-haired anime characters are here
and then the Miku's are here.
Big ol' aboos, big ol' aboos.
I like the plushy hammock idea, but I'm scared of spiders.
I've heard spiders get in there.
Is that true?
True.
Real.
Understandable.
Why did you have to bring that up?
Because, uh...
Hmm.
Oh!
This is so...
This is the cutest ever.
Oh my god.
This is so sticky cute.
What the heck?
So many minke.
Thank you.
T-posing for dominance.
Absolutely.
That's my natural state.
the door doesn't need to open wait I love these hangers it
was really cute oh I like it thank you cactus you made thank
you spiders are your friends they want to be where you like
to be I'm not a spider myself spiders are just pretty great
you think so well they're great I like eating the other bugs
but I would I wish they would eat more other bugs, like
roaches.
Wish they'd do that.
Just get a bigger spider.
Yeah, I just need a bigger spider, huh?
Let's see what we have here.
Yeah!
Development boards I've used, PCBs I've designed and made,
and PCB kits I've assembled!
Wow!
Oh!
I remember seeing this.
Cool!
I want one.
Instructions unclear.
Bought a crab instead.
What do they all do though?
What do they do?
Got in here I am.
They have a soldering station.
Wait, do you?
Can you post if you do?
Cute!
I have this Walls Girl too!
Wow, a small world.
Oh, a bulletin board featuring one normie conference badge.
Wait, where is it?
I don't see it.
Oh, it's probably this one.
Oh!
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh.
New shelf I bought this year that's already full.
Cute.
Nice.
Very nice.
Nice CD collection.
Very nice bag.
I want to see more people's CDs collection.
A cute...
Oh, God.
A paint, your sister painted him.
The eye blue.
Cute.
Cute, cute, cute.
Wait, I like the other paintings too.
Wait, this is not a painting.
I like how you can see the eye blue reflection.
In the water.
It's so...
It's like a...
It's like...
One of those Photoshopped, like, in the sky.
I kind of like...
Like that guy that goes...
You know what I'm talking about?
Oh, old shelf that got too full.
Oh my goodness.
More CDs?
She hates us?
Very cute.
Why do you look like that?
Why you look like that though?
Looks delicious.
I need it.
Thank you again for sharing!
Thank you, thank you.
Let's see.
Let me go back to blue sky.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, Usni, this looks so fancy!
what what is this do you let this you have to have a ladder
for your bookshelf bro is scholarly this is so fancy
cardinals the the the the Christmas town set up.
Oh my gosh.
Is that Wishbone?
This guy right here?
I don't know.
Might be.
The manga on the top shelf.
It's like how a fancy wine goes on the top shelf.
The finest of materials.
Goes at the very tip top.
Who needs Google when you can consult the archives?
Usni is the encyclopedia you have twilight in fact you have
the entire twilight series oh i see these blurred out photos
as well i see i see i see you that's my that's that's my why
my wife's
Wait, the...
The...
Garfield.
One of these things is not like the other.
I've never seen this.
This mint plushie is cute.
Hmm.
Garfield.
Cute!
Thanks for sharing, thanks for sharing.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's see.
I'll scroll through.
I'm gonna try and find one that...
Whoa!
Hold on.
What?
What is this?
A NASCAR bumper from 2013.
Are you really into Daskar?
It's kind of, this picture is really trippy because it feels
like it's photoshopped.
It feels like this is, wait, right?
It doesn't feel, it feels like I'm, it's hurting my eyes and
my brain a little bit.
It does, right?
This doesn't, because there's no shadow or anything.
And the headlights, those are not real.
Are those like...
The...
Finn, I'm confused.
And even this, this is like painted on, no?
Been a fan since I was a kid.
This is the most confusing.
photo I've ever seen.
NASCAR uses stickers.
They do!
Today I learned.
What?
You haven't seen cars?
Uh-uh.
I've never seen cars before.
Should we do a watch-along?
I just know perfume is in there.
In one of the movies.
Headlights are heavy and not very aerodynamic.
Groucho!
I met Owen Wilson.
He's very nice.
He is...
Lightning McQueen.
Huh.
And then also...
Wow, you're really into cars!
You need a better display case than this.
This is what I mean, I meant earlier when I say, like, I
like when my display cases are all glass because it's easier
to see in there.
This car uses fiberglass bodies because they all have the
same chassis, but just different bodies.
to make cars more similar also less debris that's that's
that's scary this room earns a score of hell yeah
chassis oh chassis chassis I learned fast and furious very
cool collection
I love the BP tanker truck.
Just like the real ones.
It's so good.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
I love for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
And then a few guitar controllers I've collected.
These are so cool.
Wait, what happened to this one?
In the middle.
Wait, I love the...
The...
Wait, the displays for these.
That's so cool!
Wow!
It fell.
Oh no!
These are so cool.
awesome though I'm
observing very cool guitar you are the guitar hero you're
the guitar Qatar Cachow hero wait I've never seen like the
the these like little hangers for them though it's cute cute
Cute, cute.
I didn't know there was such a variety of guitar
controllers.
Are there more than this?
Like, is how...
I mean, I was never into guitar hero.
But some of these, like, are really...
Like, the classic-looking ones.
Like, this one looks, like, almost like acoustic.
There are way more.
Really?
Tons.
Wow.
That's so fun.
You should get more.
You should get more, Finn.
Go, B.
buy more go spend more money there's quite a few and they've
gone back into production recently because of fortnite what
wait why because of because of because of fortnite i have
more oh oh what is this i managed to snag one of the posters
from off kai 24 when they were taking them off oh she's so
wrinkly
Fortnite has a rhythm game mode.
Oh!
She's so wrinkly.
Very cool, very cool.
Thanks for sharing.
Alright, let's see if I can find a few more.
I'm loving...
Thank you, everybody, who shared their...
I love looking at the VTuber collections.
I love looking at collections.
I'm really honored when you put me in your collections.
Thank you!
I'm very, very honored.
So thank you very much.
Let's see.
Oh my gosh, Tori, you're a Chica idol.
Shelf is so stinking cute.
Oh my god.
I love this description.
I just moved everything.
I just moved so everything is messy still.
Where?
Mess?
Messy.
Where?
The...
The light?
I don't think I belong in such a cute room!
Kangal!
Oh my gosh!
I don't belong here!
Ow!
Oh my god, twist.
This is so cute!
Do do do.
Wait, I'm obsessed with the axolotl on the pink pink.
And the Hanamaru!
It's pink.
The pink monster.
Oh my gosh, you really are a Jedi girly.
Wait, the Lego!
This is amazing.
The Lego bouquet.
I'm so obsessed.
You can clearly see part of the room is pixelated.
They haven't fully rendered it in yet.
The Tsikawa's in the ghost!
Their favorite color must be yellow.
Must be.
Wait, I'm getting such inspiration from this.
The curtains with the ribbon!
I love it!
it so much.
I can't wait to move so I can redecorate everything and
reorganize everything.
I can't convince me that an actual princess doesn't live
here.
So the Vita bag is... Oh my god!
I'm so obsessed.
I'm sorry that I'm that I am mint.
I need to make more pink merch.
Wait, and the ghost lights!
The ghost fairy lights are so cute!
It's a complimentary color.
I need to become... I need to become more pink, more blue.
Redo my color scheme.
I rename myself and everything.
I could still be named Mint and not be the color mint
probably it's pink this is like oh my gosh I don't even
notice the pixel because I was just looking at all the walls
girls and they're so cute oh so cute everything's so cute
your little princess bed I want to serve you I like the
princess that you are let me be your made please.
Minto is an accent.
Oh, she in this pink room.
Rin, thank you so much for sharing your cute otaku room.
So cute.
So stinking cute.
Okay.
I'll do one more.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many good...
So many, so many good rooms!
They're all so good!
I want to feature everybody.
I'm like scrolling through and I'm like...
And then I scroll through and I'm like...
And then I scroll and I'm like...
All of them are so good!
Everything is so nice!
Good job, everybody.
Good job.
I'm in the middle of building a minch shrine in my office
Couldn't make it for this stream, but I hope to show it off
in the future Oh, thank you
Thank you Oh, yeah, we'll do another one for sure Oh my
gosh, everything is I'm like so, I'm so Wow, wow, what is
this?
Okay, what the heck is this?
Okay.
Too much of...
My room's too much of a mess to show off.
But here's a collection of a gacha poem from my Japan trip
as well as my humble collection of CDs.
Yeah, okay, well, like, you talk about that.
But first of all, I love that you went to Jam Akihabara.
Good, good, good, good, good.
Good, good, good.
And then...
I guess these are your gacha.
But, um, why did you...
Oh, here's your CDs.
Ah!
I have some of these... I have...
This blue archive one too.
Um...
I was very excited about your A1 collab.
Thank you!
But, uh... What is this?
Why don't you make any mention of that in your description?
We're just gonna...
We're just gonna pass up the...
Pass over the...
The cosplay?
With me in the belt!
It looks sick!
It's so cool!
Normal house decoration.
This is why if you buy, if you also get like the Minto
cosplay, you could set it up like this and you could just
always have, you know, a little ghost haunts in your house.
Wow!
It looks so good!
Oh my god!
John Elden Ring.
It looks so awesome!
Oh my gosh, thank you for sharing.
Okay, I'm gonna like just try and click through a bunch.
Look at all your warhammer!
Miniatures!
Tasme!
It's amazing.
Working on an otaku full sleeve tattoo!
Maybe I could sneak Aminto in somewhere for the collection.
Oh my gosh.
Don't tattoo me on your body.
But I would love to see an otaku tattoo.
Oh my gosh.
I love this setup.
with this setup.
I love the camels.
I love the camels up here, but I love the lighting.
It's so warm and cozy.
I love warm lighting like this.
And you framed from the cafe.
Llama.
This is so beautiful.
Come haunt me for a bit, Minto.
I'm here.
I love love love the setup that's so nice i'm scroll what
are these my collection is painting miniatures this isn't
all of them but it's the most recent ones i painted hello
the shading on these
this looks incredible this is amazing wow oh my god They're
so beautiful!
They're so nice looking!
I wonder how much time it took, yeah.
Wow, very awesome paintwork.
Wait, there's more?
Is that Lucia?
What?
Oh my gosh.
So this is...
This is...
This is a hole.
Cool!
Really, really cool.
Some close-up shots.
Wait.
Oh, we'll do the full room.
Look at all that, Minto!
I love to see you hang up the cosplay.
Nice little decoration.
I'm on the CRT.
So good.
This is so cute!
Everything is so cute!
Tom Nook.
Lamp.
Kitty!
Oh, these are the close-ups.
Thank you, Bert, for sharing.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's see, let's see.
You have Croc Collection.
No, no, it's these damn Squidward's from Don Quixote
yesterday.
What are the pink ones?
They're really cute, though.
I like the Minecraft ones a lot, too.
It's these dang Squidward's.
Let's see what else we got.
What else we got?
Thank you.
everybody for for including me in your collections i
appreciate it so much i'm very very honored to have a space
in your home so thank you thank you holy amiibos look at all
the amiibos look at all the nintendo's snake snake
Astrobot Sand's Undertale Astrobot Astrobot Astrobot Oh cute
Oh my gosh Not the GamerSubs cups all down there We have to
fix Goodas bangs They're all messed up So cute Oh my gosh
Thank you Oh my goodness.
Oh my, some of these are kind of spicy.
Spicy.
A little spicy.
A little spice going.
Oh!
That's Leo.
That's my friend.
Wait.
Whoa.
Oh.
Yes, Minto, I would like to participate in the Butaku review
here on my Daki Makura.
These are really cute though.
I love big tapestries.
I'm such a fan.
Thank you for sharing.
Thank you, thank you for sharing.
Oh my god, there's more!
There's even more!
I do that too though.
Sometimes like you can hang your...
Also, do you live in a school?
What is the ceiling?
This is like an office ceiling.
But um, you can like put your daki makura kind of like
hanging like on the wall on the ceiling like this too.
Come in me.
That's me.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Thank you for sharing.
Oh.
Red dress.
Oh my gosh.
Men in your giant eyeball outfit.
Oh.
This is fun, guys.
This was fun.
Thank you for sharing all your passions with me.
Whether they are...
Uh...
Taki Makura!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
Okay, let me argue.
I need to argue again.
Remember how I said putting things in frames?
Enhances everything!
Look at that!
Look how beautiful!
Wow!
It looks amazing!
Wow, and the shelf too!
Riccadette!
Looks so good!
Enhanced cheeks.
Cheeks everywhere.
Cheek, cheek, cheek, cheek, cheek.
100% increases the vibes and cleanliness.
Yes, yes, yes.
Thank you, everybody, for the amazing rooms.
I wish I could have gotten to everyone.
Sorry that I...
didn't tend to go for a little bit longer today but just
just my vibes are off too so I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
rest and uh I think you guys should as well because it's the
weekend a little bit still most maybe not for everybody but
just a little bit who are you Miffy I love Miffy I love I
love Miffy.
I love Miffy.
So cute!
Wait, I'm like the same size as Miffy here.
This is a good one to end on.
Miffy.
And Chimarin.
So cute!
Thank you!
It's cool to see everyone's awesome collections and hear
your commentary.
Hope you're feeling better and have a great night.
Maybe get some Chinese and ice cream.
So many great possibilities.
I really enjoy being able to peek into your guys' lives a
little bit.
And honestly, I'm so shocked at how many, me being so much
of a part of your lives.
So thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Hi, hi, Minto.
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Community sharing is my favorite.
Thank you.
I'm gonna just honestly browse this.
Like, I was browsing it before stream, so now I'm just gonna
browse through it afterwards.
Thank you for checking out my room!
Thank you, Blue Blaze!
I was in a sad mood earlier and the stream cheered me up.
I hope you're feeling better.
Well, I'm glad you're feeling better, rather.
Why?
Thank you, thank you.
Hope you're feeling better.
Minky YouTube seems to be mad at me.
Oh no!
I wonder why.
What would you do?
What'd you do?
Don't forget about Miffy Uniqlo drop tomorrow.
I have it in my calendar!
Wait, I have to set an alarm to wake up for it.
I'll submit my room next time?
Okay.
Don't feel like you have to submit your full room, you guys.
I say it's a room review, but it's really like, uh just kind
of whatever things you're passionate about so it doesn't
have to be a vtubers it doesn't have to be anime at all it
can be you know we've had lots of we had lots of stuff we
had like transformers we had we had photography like it's
otaku window yeah yeah yeah so just please feel free to
submit anything that you're passionate about yeah yeah mint
haunts us all through the screen into our homes absolutely
thanks for checking out my croc collection the pink ones are
a post in Malone that guy has crocs I hope to collect many
more I will look forward next time I will look forward to
more crocs we love our cheeky goose to me thank you thanks
for the captain made it without being perceived not for long
camp control thank you for checking out my cave me though
can't wait to be Surround by more Minky when my merch gets
here.
Kiwawa!
What are you doing here?
Explain yourself.
Wait, what did I do?
Oh.
Wait.
Is this about yesterday?
Oh!
Look at my tweet.
Oh no!
Wait.
Mint is planning to eat me?
Okiyori, you have to understand.
You own a restaurant!
I'd like to know how to get fan merch of Minto, so I want
that big Aibu to put next to the big Minto Fubo.
Big Aibu.
I think, like, conventions, but I'm sure there could be
people to help you.
Thank you so much for the part, Yutu!
First time super chat.
Taco, thank you!
really cool to look at everyone's collections they all feel
really awesome they made me feel like i need to step up my
game hope i can make it next time yeah i look forward to
thank you for the super chat can't stay good night good
night don't worry brandon we're about ending the way she
just brushes off the scandalous thing would you eat all of
me or just a bite i think i think you are once i start have
i been able to stop I think once I start I can't stop baby
how would we ever collab again I
didn't consider this possibility finger-licking good yeah
you're a Phoenix you have to be reborn I genuinely have no
idea what I did Does YouTube be in YouTube?
Think, vid, think!
I'll be- I'll make sure to post a more updated version of my
room with all my Minto merch next time.
We get to see the legend's room?
The legend?
I can't be reborn when- and that's my only weakness.
Well then every stream would be a collab!
I guess I missed out on this but hopefully I can join the
next time.
Yeah!
Thank you, Maddie!
night too
i can't believe this honestly kiara i said you're number one
because you are my number one but also i just wanted doki to
feel bad because i don't want her to have the satisfaction
of being number one
for my own safety i must just no
Yes, that's the true purpose.
Thank you guys for sharing all your rooms.
I really appreciate it.
Taking the time to clean and take photos and upload them.
Can't just be saying this stuff, man.
Stream is super fun.
Thanks, man.
Thank you.
Australia's... Not Australia.
Not Australia.
But I will... I will...
I will peer into your rooms and into your lives next time.
My Ace Combat bait didn't work.
Wait, you're the one that had the Ace Combat on the TV,
right?
I definitely saw it, and I was looking at your playing
models and everything.
I wanted to put it on.
I did.
see it though I did I did I'm gonna go through everybody's
posts after this too I'm just gonna like look through them
because they're so fun so so fun oh my gosh like I see yours
duckie with your firefly your wife Wow there's so many
awesome figure collections kitty hope you like mine if you
see it I will
yeah there are a lot of good ones yeah so many so many so
many but thank you everybody thank you thank you thank you I
will see you when I see you next and if you keep mine check
replies trust wait oh my gosh Matia just got to you
is that me with David Hayter is that me with David Hayter
Thank you, everyone!
Thank you, Otsumito, Otsumito, Otsumito!
And I will see you when I see you next!
Ita-dashai!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
Bye-bye!